getting back to just your acting career
and how you're perceived so you came
from the world of modeling and then
you've been in LA and think you've just
been signed which congratulations yeah
so when you when you go out for an
audition and you say you'd like to kind
of surprised you maybe come in more
subdued and then bring the range and
people are kind of blown away is that
what you're talking about
you know actually to be honest I
actually think it's the it's the
opposite it's funny
bravado there's a very thin line between
bravado confidence and arrogance and I
think as an actor you have to tow that
line you know you really have to
understand you really have to believe in
the work that you're doing you have to
believe in the perspective that you're
bringing to the material you believe in
the choices that you've made coming into
the room and so I mean the word that
comes to mind is cocksure is that
there's a certain cocksure attitude that
you have to have because if you're going
to inspire confidence in a director or a
casting director and a producer and a
creative team you have that confidence
has to first start with yourself so I
would say rather than going going in
subdued or meek I go in with these are
the choices I've made this is the level
of professionalism bringing to the
project and unless you draw your own
opinions based on upon that so yeah
because I think I think it'd be too easy
to go and subdued for me to just become
exactly what they would want me to be
which which is not what I which is not
what I am I know I've asked this
question in other interviews but if
someone doesn't have that what you want
to say cocksure or whatever it is where
do they find it because not everybody
has it they have voices from the past or
whatever that are always like in their
ear even though those people's really
long gone but where does that come from
if you don't already have it well I mean
I know I can only speak for myself but I
know exactly what you're saying because
for me it comes from a deep
vulnerability and and from it's sort of
born out of insecurity which is a little
counterintuitive but it's it's
confidence born out of insecurity so I
I'm aware of how insecure I can
and how I can let doubts creep into my
mind and it's my reaction to that which
is exactly what you're doing with the
work it's your reaction to the material
that really drives the whole thing
forward it's the same thing with me and
in that regard so yeah
you